I do think that sports betting on a
widespread legalized basis in the United
States is inevitable on your point about
reducing the number of games ultimately
I don't think that's something one that
our our fans necessarily want Kobe's
back I'm gonna finally learn the
triangle
you know the mix are here in town and
Phil's teaching it
hello we are very pleased to be joined
here today at bleacher report by the
Commissioner of the NBA Adam Silver Adam
thank you so much for joining us
appreciate you being here my pleasure
it's it's an exciting time NBA seasons
about to start your first opening night
actually as commissioner although not
your first opening night so many things
going on
Kobe's returned Derrick Rose's return a
lot of interesting storylines and oh by
the way LeBrons back in Cleveland
what's got you most intrigued about the
upcoming season well let me begin with
opening night it's of course the first
time that I get to give out the rings so
that's what I'm most excited about at
the moment and especially to such great
champions as the San Antonio Spurs and a
first-class organization so that's a
treat you know it's a it's it's a
privilege as part of this job that I get
to do that but I'd say generally I can't
wait for the season it got a taste of it
in the summer league with some of the
rookies coming in you know as you know a
much anticipated class as you said
Kobe's back you know I'm gonna finally
learn the triangle you know the mix are
here in town and Phil's teaching it
there's actually X movie I'm gonna watch
spikes documentary explaining the
triangle once and for all so it's really
just back to basketball there's so many
in in my job there's so many things that
don't relate to what happens on the
court that I have to focus on that at
Roode I'm a fan and I can't remember a
time when there were so many interesting
storylines
throughout the league I think it's a
testament in part to the collective
bargaining agreement you probably gonna
ask me about that but I think it's
working I mean put aside the financial
side of it I mean the percentage of Bri
and all that but I think the system
elements as you know and you covered it
extensively were designed to create a
more competitive league in terms of the
distribution of players and we're seeing
that and I think in addition the fact
that as the popularity of this game
grows more of the best athletes and more
of the best athletes and around the
world are turning to basketball and I
think you're seeing that in terms of the
quality of the play on the court yeah I
would agree and obviously the Eastern
Conference becoming very competitive
again the West is obviously brutally
competitive so there is I think to a
degree a lot of parity especially at the
top of each
I want to ask you about you did mention
that a lot of the job of course is the
off the court stuff Board of Governors
meeting recently lottery forum did not
pass now tanking was a huge issue last
year you said yourself there's a
corrosive effect perception-wise even if
maybe it's not as widespread as people
believe is lottery reform now dead or
dormant it's definitely not dead so as
you know a majority of the team's 17
teams they voted in favor of the
specific proposal that the competition
committee had recommended to the board
but it requires a 3/4 vote to change our
playing rules and so since a majority of
the teams want something different it's
definitely not dead
I don't think there's quite a sense of
urgency as you know we've tinkered with
the draft lottery format multiple times
over the years and as I said the other
day I'm not necessarily dissatisfied
with where we've come out in terms of
the odds for the worst performing team
versus the you know the other teams that
don't make the playoffs but you said it
I am concerned about the perception not
just the perception that teams may not
be doing everything in their power to
win games but what I see as the
increased pressure actually on general
managers and even owners in this league
to underperform I mean that's what's new
I don't remember any time in my history
there would look the very purpose that
the lottery was put in place and that
was before I got to the league was to
disincentivize teams from having an
incentive to have the worst record I'm
not going to use the T word that you use
but what's happened now is and I think
it's the advent of analytics and a new
generation of general managers and a lot
more sophistication among the fans as
well that fans have adopted it as
insight at least they've there's a
perception that it's a winning strategy
I don't necessarily agree with that and
I think the jury is out on the analytics
and I think part of it is the cultural
elements of not being a winning
organization and I think mark you
he said the other day too that when it
may be an effective strategy if it's one
team but when you have multiple teams
racing to the bottom I think that it
takes away the effectiveness for
potentially all of those teams so I do
think it needs to be addressed I you
know I I thought that was a very
productive discussion in front of the
board on the potential unintended
consequences and that's always the
concern when you tinker with the a
program like the draft lottery because
the teams are so sophisticated I mean in
a good way it's they're they're highly
competitive and they're always looking
for an edge so I think the sense of the
room was again clear the majority of
teams were voting for that specific
proposal but when it didn't pass there
was then a second resolution in essence
that was that that was passed that in
which we agreed as a board that we
needed to turn back to this so we will
is it inevitable then do you think a
year from now there will be something
whether it was the timing that people
quibble with or whether it was the
actual formula are we going to see a
different version in place maybe by this
time next year I don't want to say
inevitable because the board is
definitely not a rubber stamp and
whatever process we use in terms of a
competition committee I mean I want to
encourage a very full conversation once
we do get to the full board of owners so
III think it's likely but but we'll see
we'll see as this season goes on III
think also as there's more public
attention focused on the issue it may
affect the behavior of our teams as well
sure another area that you guys have
kind of looked to maybe tinker with you
had a 44 minute preseason game trying
that out what did you want to see or get
out of that was that about trying to
decrease a little bit of the toll on
players was that about more fitting into
a time slot for your TV partners would
what did you want to see all of the
above I mean I it was a fascinating
experiment in that
there's been a lot of discussion about
length of game over the years not just
in our sport but in all sports I think
people have picked on baseball certainly
more than our sport but I always said
when I was a kid movies were two and a
half hours long and now they're two
hours I think if you were designing the
NBA from scratch today I'm not sure if
where we'd end up is with a two and a
half hour game in terms of actual clock
time of course it's 48 minutes in terms
of the game itself I don't necessarily
think the answer is fewer minutes to the
game I mean art it's not as if our fans
are telling us they want to see fewer
minutes on the court clearly our fans
are telling us that we should take a
fresh look at the format I remember in
the 44 minute experiment it wasn't just
the reduction of clock time we also took
out two of the commercial breaks as well
now we have to balance the commercial
needs of the league and the players
against the entertainment value in the
running time as well but but what was
also beneficial with a 44 minute
experiment is that it gets people
thinking about the issue may be in the
same reference back to the draft lottery
and that there's so many smart minds out
there outside of the league frankly
yours included and your colleagues had
the bleach report that when you do a 44
minute experiment what you get is a lot
of free research that people weigh in
and say well maybe not 44 minutes but
you know maybe you should look at the
format maybe you should change the the
actual schedule and that for example
that's something we continue to look at
it may be that in ultimately in terms of
the players there are better ways to
rest them then reduce the number of
minutes we're adding an all-star break
this year or we're lengthening the break
back-to-backs are of course an issue for
players and our teams and so maybe we
need to begin the season a little bit
earlier reduce the preseason go a little
bit longer in June to space the season
add a little bit more so those are all
considerations but the good idea is
continue to pour in after the 44 minute
experiment you know now that was a very
interesting discussion as you said it
kind of got sparked by this and players
immediately weighed in with look we're
fine with 48 minute games
but could we play fewer than 82 now I'm
not even gonna ask because I know that
there are reasons revenue highs that I
don't think the owners or players would
ever go for that but is it a reasonable
proposition to simply cut the preseason
in half start earlier eliminate all
back-to-backs if that's possible is that
something that you think clearly the
players would love to go that route is
that a realistic possibility for the
lead to pursue yeah it is I think that
is something we'll take a close look at
I mean their revenue revenue
implications - for pre-season and when I
say revenue implications it's not just
reducing the number of domestic
preseason games as you know we've taken
advantage of that opportunity that month
of October to really grow our business
internationally I was in Berlin with the
Spurs just two weeks ago
then I went on to China with the nets
and the kings and you know we in those
markets we get questions about bringing
regular-season games but what I point
out especially in China is that the fact
that we play in the preseason gives us
the luxury of coming over from multiple
days player spending time sightseeing
you know experiencing the culture
running clinics doing charitable events
all kinds of things that we couldn't do
we just jump the players jumped on a
plane played a game overseas and came
back so those are things we have to take
into account looking into preseason but
I I think the players are right I mean I
think those are interesting suggestions
on your point about reducing the number
of games I also ultimately I don't think
that's something one that our our fans
necessarily want I understand from the
players standpoint although they love
the competition I mean I think we
reduced the number of seasons depends
where the player you know whether you're
on a winning team I mean remember for a
lot of our players they finish their
season in April I mean you can argue I
mean for our better players they're
playing well into June so there's that
disparity right there and ultimately in
terms of number in games and minutes
just real quickly in terms of the goal
though do you believe that you could
possibly extend the length of your
players careers and especially the elite
ones who do have a lot more games from
mid-april to mid-may reducing something
whether it's number of games whether
it's number of total minutes whether
it's number of preseason games whether
it's eliminating back to backs do you
think there is the medical case
to be made out there that guys could
have longer careers fewer injuries by
making one of these attacks you know how
would the only thing I can say is I've
learned the hard way in this business
not necessarily necessarily to trust my
gut on an issue like that but to look at
the data I think that's where analytics
do come in I mean as you remember when
we were kids guys took the entire summer
off you know and training camp was the
opportunity maybe to lose a few pounds
that you'd gained in the summer and
truly get back in shape I don't think
anyone would suggest today that the fact
that guys did virtually nothing in the
summer was necessarily better
health-wise and finding that right
balance because we know even if even if
players don't participate for their
national with their national team over
the summer or aren't actively playing
they're working out hard you know and
sometimes what I've heard from some of
the trainer's is that the the
repetitiveness of some of the things
they're doing on their own instead of
playing games isn't necessarily good you
know in the long term for their tendons
or their muscles so I think we got it
we need more science here and that's
that's something also that the league is
taking very seriously I mean we're you
know it we had extensive discussions at
the owners meeting about that as well
and that is you know what should we be
doing collectively as a league in terms
of gathering medical data so they're
always going to be competitive issues
with teams and some teams think they
have the secret sauce in terms of rehab
in terms of the appropriate training but
I think the owners are increasingly of
the view that at least a certain amount
of that information should be shared
because as a league we all have an
interest in extending the careers of our
players especially our star players yeah
absolutely now one of the hallmarks I
would say of your administration so far
you're eight months as the Commissioner
is the phrase of fresh look you want to
take a fresh look at just about
everything and we've seen that with the
the lottery the statute of limitations
is going to be up soon right is no
longer fresh I guess right but you did
extend the all-star break there have
been a number of these things where you
basically said you know what why not go
back to 2 2 1 1 1 for the finals right
why not have a longer all-star break
there's been a lot of that and I think
people have appreciated kind of that
that that fresh look one of the things
you threw out that I think caught people
off guard a little bit
middle of July was why not have a
midseason tournament and I kind of got
everybody's attention got a little bit
of buzz going we haven't heard much
about it since what's the likelihood of
a midseason tournament what would that
look like well by the way I mean that
goes to the whole issue of length of
season as well and I realize you can't
just take the existing 82 games schedule
regular season plus playoffs and then
just plop another tournament down on top
of it I think you'd have to take a
serious look at the all-star break if it
were midseason tournament the game
itself the events around all-star but
conceivably what a midseason tournament
could look like is you could have some
number of teams and it might you you
could either begin with all the teams
and have a single elimination type
tournament I think again it's another
area where through floating the idea
I've gotten some really interesting
suggestions over the transom so to speak
it may be an opportunity to bring in
some international clubs I mean there's
been talk about the NBA sponsoring a
world championship of types of course
there's the World Basketball World Cup
now which the u.s. participates USA
Basketball but for the NBA of course
Club championships are very different
and we I and others at the league office
have spent a lot of time studying the
Champions League for European soccer
other types of cups and midseason
tournaments they have now they are
there's a long tradition they but but
maybe there's an opportunity to create a
new tradition and to create more
competitions I mean right now
everything's about the Larry O'Brien
trophy and European soccer operates or a
little bit differently they have other
cups which maybe aren't the equivalent
of the championship but in their own
right are highly significant and so
those are the kinds of things those
aren't the changes that are going to
happen in a year and maybe you know not
even in in two or three years but the
kinds of development for the league that
need to be studied over time it's why we
have a competition committee a so so and
and by the way on on the on the fresh
look point I mean in all seriousness I
think whether it's a sports league or
any industry or you know your company I
assume you're constantly read looking at
the way you do things and
it may be because the acceleration of
media because of the Internet look how
quickly the bleacher report has emerged
as a factor I mean so much news in
sports whether it's in the NBA or other
leagues has been broken by you know I
don't want to say you know bloggers I
don't want to miss you know whether it's
TMZ frankly Deadspin bleacher report the
whole media landscape has changed so I
think we'd be crazy you know not to
constantly be taking a fresh look at
everything we do the NBA had been among
the league's that actually sued the
state of New Jersey trying to prevent
expanded gambling on sports and it's
been something that I think the sports
leagues have generally been very very
reluctant to see you've talked about
this being almost an inevitability the
expanded legalized sports gambling and
your position is I think a little
different than what the NBA has kind of
stood for before which is hey look if
it's coming anyway embrace it
participate in it and see where it
meshes with your own goals can you
explain how that can possibly mesh when
when the NBA has clearly been so opposed
to that in the past yeah well well first
of all our position in the case of the
the ongoing lawsuit in New Jersey is
that there is federal legislation pass
pas and that the bill that the state of
New Jersey has passed is not consistent
with the past but framework and
therefore is ultimately unconstitutional
or put differently that pass by is
constitutional and that it's regulated
by the federal government having said
that I do think that sports betting on a
widespread legalized basis in the United
States is inevitable in part because
states like New Jersey are pushing hard
to generate additional revenue in the
same way that lotteries have expanded to
virtually every state now I think sports
betting will follow behind my view is
that if that is inevitable and it's
going to happen that we need to
participate in the regulatory framework
that will be designed around our game I
mean ultimately we have the
responsibility for the integrity
of the game to ensure the competition is
pure to ensure that no one around in the
NBA family whether that be at the league
a team a referee is in any way
influenced by gamblers we of course do
all those things now but frankly because
the industry is not transparent we we
can't do as good a job I believe as we
could if it were all highly regulated I
mean for example right now there's a
huge offshore online business and sports
betting if you go to Google or now that
Steve Ballmer reminded me the other day
now that he's an owner if you go to Bing
and you put in bet fill-in-the-blank
sports league you could spend your night
looking at the various sites that asked
people to enter their credit cards and
so there's no doubt there's a large
whether it's a gray area of the law or
illegal area what that's happening right
now in addition it is legal in Europe to
bet on the NBA we of course are
enormously popular in many markets
outside the United States where there's
widespread betting on our games legal
betting on our games and and it's
another exam works they have in places
they have in place in other areas of the
world so my view is if it's going to
happen
we should participate we should have a
seat at the table we should be talking
about the appropriate ways to regulate
it and control it in the same way
frankly of course it's legal in Nevada
right now in a highly regulatory
framework I don't want to hide from the
fact there are business benefits to it
as well if you look at for example the
English Premier League one of the
largest categories for sponsorship are
the betting companies I mean they're
whether it's on the jerseys whether it's
on the the court side that the signs on
the side of the pitch you know or the
field you know and in that sport
obviously where they don't have
commercials or that there's a whole
different model but there's a commercial
opportunity as well and I think that
sports betting if done in an appropriate
regulatory environment is not
necessarily an evil I think that you
know
people if you look at the popularity of
office pools for n-c-double-a tournament
you know weekend bets that people have
in this country on other sports it's you
know of course there's the potential and
I think you have that no different than
with alcohol or other substances -
there's the potential for abuse but I
don't necessarily think that means that
for the 95% of the population that can
do it in a controlled enjoyable way and
be entertained by it that it necessarily
should therefore be excluded for
everyone no it certainly engages fans on
a whole other level when they have that
bet on the table and they're they're
that much more interested I understand
the way it works in European soccer
leagues you can actually bet when you're
even at the stadium is there gonna be a
day maybe someday down the road I'm not
saying imminently but where you go to an
NBA arena and there's a window to go and
put your bet down well it's a great
question and historically for a European
soccer you could bet at the stadiums and
for example at Wembley I remember going
years ago and seeing the windows the
betting windows right at the games and
thinking my god how different this is
than the United States but what's
happened now and in a way very close to
heart in terms of your business it's all
moved online and so there are still some
of those windows left but even from a
control and regulatory standpoint the
regulators would prefer that people bet
online because when they bet online it's
through a credit card it's easier to
identify the person it's not just
somebody walking up to a window and
putting down cash and so what you're
seeing now at the stadiums is that an
online has come to mean for the most
part mobile and it's not necessarily
bets on who is gonna win the match but
it's more in the category of so-called
proposition bets what's going to happen
in the first half or what's going to
happen in the first 10 minutes or you
know all kinds of permutations on bets
and so what you see now and a lot of
European soccer games is people on their
smartphones placing bets during the
games and so while I don't think it's
we're net we're going to move to a
framework we're going to have betting
windows in arenas I you know I think
though as you see the
way the world's going you're gonna see
people increasingly betting on tablets
and phones and incidentally I happen to
see that all the time at games now I
mean again both sites are out there I
mean I'm not even qualified in terms of
their ultimate legality but they're
there's a lot of them out there right
now and I see fans all the time when I
sit in the stands at games looking at
their phones looking at iPads other
tablets and you can you can see what
they're doing and they're placing bets
throughout the game another wrinkle in
the NBA this season that I thought I
wanted to have you address because it's
very interesting Becky Hammon is going
to be the first female full-time
assistant coach with the San Antonio
Spurs Michele Roberts was just hired by
the Union to be their executive director
that's a first
Lauren Holt camp another female referee
coming up to join violet Palmer it's an
interesting kind of just a you know
chain of events here all happening at
once your league this is happening and I
have not seen anything remotely to this
degree with NFL Major League Baseball
what do you think is there any theory
you have why the NBA seems to have a bit
a different environment here where it
seems like women are really moving into
all areas and is this the start of even
bigger wave coming down the road I saw
it I'm not qualified to comment on
what's happening in other leagues I'd
say in terms of the NBA so much credit
goes to David Stern and to our owners
and through the family around this
league it's a very progressive
environment I think I you know what
Coach pop you know he I think he's built
the kind of excellence there by making
decisions on talent and that are that
are neutral of nationality ethnicity
color you name it and I think we're
seeing it's it's a little embarrassing
that four steps that frankly are not
that progressive that we should be
getting any credit but I'm I'm honored
to be part of it and I think that
ultimately it's my job and the league
offices job to set the right culture
throughout the league so I think it is a
byproduct of that I think that if you
look at the track record of the NBA
going back well before I was ever
involved in the league and even before
David Stern was ever involved in the
league there's been a lot of firsts that
have happened in this league in terms of
african-american general managers
African American coaches African
American principle owners and hopefully
the next step you're seeing in terms of
gender real advancement as well but but
it's something we talk about a lot at
the league office it's something we
talked about in our just recent set of
owners meetings there were lots of
discussions about inclusion and
diversity respect in the workplace and
so we are very focused on it and I I
mean I I couldn't be happy for Becky
Hammon but asper said it just right that
they weren't looking I think to you know
you know put a marker down in the
history books they're looking to win
championships and I think ultimately
that's what inclusion and diversity are
about and that is competing at the
highest level and I think the best
organizations realized that to be the
best you have to have the greatest pool
of applicants and hire the best we're
coming down toward the end of our time
here but I've got some lightning around
quick good question anyway I got a
little more time I appreciate that will
will though it won't be quite like it I
had a long answer so you're right yeah
okay freeze frame your all time starting
five in the NBA any era not fair you
know I I work for one of them and that's
Michael Jordan because 130 owners so
he's on the court the reason I can't I
don't feel comfortable answering that
question is because I have too many
friends over my 22 plus years in the
league to be picking and choosing of
course mr. Russell you know somebody
else why I have the good fortune of
working with on a regular basis he would
be there too but I'm gonna stop there
because I'm gonna only get myself in
trouble alright fair enough fair enough
I don't want you to offend any of your
your friends in the league obviously
although speaking of which I think you
and I discussed this once before
you
met obviously players of all kind of
stature of all kinds of Fame from all
across the the history of the league who
have you met that you were actually
intimidated by nervous to meet Bill
Russell still I think from my early days
in the league
I remember my my father told me a story
my father was no longer alive when I
first came to the NBA told me a story
about how he and my oldest brother Eric
had waited outside the old garden in New
York to get Bill Russell autograph and
how Bill when Bill Russell had come out
he had barked at them because of course
you notoriously doesn't sign autographs
I was thinking dad didn't you know that
back then like I hope it wasn't sold out
that you were standing out there waiting
but um I think only because bill had he
was so you know he's so legendary he's
so accomplished I mean and he's lived so
much history I mean back to some of the
you know some of the early milestones we
were talking about before I mean he was
there you know when Martin Luther King
you know made his famous civil rights
speech you know in Washington DC and and
so he intimidates me a little bit as a
historical figure
just because he's seen so much and as I
always say to people you know about the
NBA they forget what a young league we
are I mean it's it's like if you worked
in baseball and somebody said you want
to sit with Babe Ruth you know at a game
that's what to me it's like sitting with
Bill Russell yeah now your job is
obviously all-consuming I don't know if
there's time for anything else but what
are you doing when you're not watching
basketball or otherwise managing the
league any outside hobbies well I enjoy
running still I think you know I've run
two marathons over the years I'm not
running such long distances anymore but
I try to find time to run I'm fortunate
to live near Central Park and I have a
dog I have a Labrador Retriever and in
New York one of the greatest things
about New York City is that before 9:00
a.m. and after 9:00 p.m. you don't have
to have your dog on its leash on its
leash in Central Park so that's sort of
really fun kind of hobby you know
relaxation for me go
at the park with my dog and throwing the
ball and stuff like that I don't watch
as much non sports television as I used
to I find that it's pretty all-consuming
when with the amount of mba programming
on the amount of NBA coverage there is
on the internet but I love movies you
know I I try to get to as many movies as
I can last one you saw oh my god it's
such an unfair question I got to think
for a second we can we can move on Steve
Ballmer new one over the LA Clippers you
mentioned him earlier
a very energetic guy described him in 20
words or less he is the most
enthusiastic person I've ever met
i sat with him at a Clippers game before
he bought the team and he was bellowing
so loud I mean I I generally don't sit
with owners at games but he wasn't an
owner there but people kept looking
around like what's that noise emanating
from my row and it was Steve yelling and
screaming and just with the crazy
enjoyment and enthusiasm during the game
but I should say on a serious note he's
extraordinarily smart again he just
attended his first Board of Governors
meetings cast a lot of really good
probing questions about materials and as
I said to him afterwards talk about a
fresh look I think when you have a new
set of eyes on materials that we've been
historically giving to teams whether
it's the way we present our financials
whether it's the way we talk about
basketball and it's some money as
accomplished as Steve Ballmer or
somebody who you know was the CEO of one
of the most successful companies in the
world it's like please you know come in
the tent and like make suggestions to us
yeah we talked a little bit about
innovation so three things that are
still on the Adam silver board and not
things that have to happen just things
you'd like to do in Bay 2 at least
consider the format of the season is
something I'm very focused on and
whether that means expanding it in a way
that allows more rests for the players
over the course of the season means
starting a little bit earlier maybe
going a little bit later that's one of
the things on my list
as we just did to new media deals in the
United States obviously we renewed with
our great partners at Turner and ESPN
and ABC but I think their enormous
opportunities international
internationally and and not just revenue
generating but for a much more
comprehensive coverage and that's as
much about what these new deals were
about I was just recently in China
there's some media companies there that
literally blow away anything that's
happened in the United States in terms
of the numbers of users of those of
those apps on social media the kinds of
technology they're using so that's and
that's incredibly fascinating to me and
I say lastly just just to name three I
continue to be consumed with the way we
can be represented visually around the
world it's something I talk about a lot
and that is well the in arena experience
is critically important especially if
you're watching a game on TV if there's
not an excited crowd around the game you
know it's you're not necessarily to be
as in food as enthusiastic a viewer if
you don't see people excited to be there
but having said that such a miniscule
fraction of our fans ever get to
experience our game in the arena not
just the United States but I can work in
the United States but more so
internationally and I think the ultimate
goal is how do we replicate that
experience how do we make it feel when
you're watching a game on television
when you have whatever mobile devices
tablets and phones with you that you
have that sense that you're part of that
larger community that people are yelling
and screaming that you can react that
you can pick angles you can look at
replays that that to me you know making
enhancing that experience for people who
are watching through whatever form of
media is on the top of my is at the top
of my agenda as well before we let you
go
we want to look a little bit even
further ahead into the future here 2024
10 years down the road a few predictions
and don't worry we're not going to hold
you to of these but true or false 2024
in the Year 2024 there will be a female
head coach in the NBA true 2020 for the
NBA we'll have teams in Europe
I know it's on the 10 year rolling cycle
that David put out there 20 years ago
but I you know I don't want to pretend I
can predict the future I don't know no
okay
true or false there will be more teams
in the United States in 2024 I think
it's possible teams could be in some
different markets but expansion is not
on our agenda right now so I won't send
the congratulations card to Seattle just
yet you know it's a difficult issue
because I I don't want to prejudge it I
think 30 teams feels right at the moment
again though I don't want to predict the
influx of great players I mean part of
it it's not just a financial issue but
it's a competitive issue and where as
you and I talked about the at the
beginning of this session we're seeing
more competitive teams than we've had
any time in history just a few years ago
reporters like you were writing that
this diluted league wasn't producing
great competition every night so the
last thing I want to do is quickly talk
about adding more teams I know I'm not
working in your foot that's ok we're not
you and I fight not the lightening part
I got to speed you up all right in the
year 2024 the NBA will have a true minor
league system 30 d-league teams with 30
affiliations with the top NBA teams true
true that would be that would be a great
move in the year 2020 for LeBron James
will have equaled Michael Jordan with
six championships I'm not making any
pretty championship calls that's that's
fair enough
easier one for you here I think the year
2020 for Gregg Popovich will have
retired as coach of the San Antonio
Spurs and will be a sideline reporter
for one of the true the greatest thing
wouldn't it I would love to see him turn
the tables and finally in the year 2024
Adam silver will be Commissioner of the
NBA
boy that's the last prediction I'm gonna
make I mean especially I'm not gonna
speak for our owners all I can say is
I'm fully engaged right now and I love
my job
fantastic thank you very much Adam
silver Adam Silver Commissioner of the
NBA here with us at bleacher report
Thank You Howard Adam thank you